an express burial in the middle of the
night that's how we see arrow had to
bury his father gift all by the order of
the Nicaraguan government his father
allegedly had cope with 19 when I
entered the cemetery I had to act
naturally because there were orders that
the body must be buried and there was no
turning back so the only thing I could
try to do was to stream it so that my
friends on Facebook could be there with
me at the time reports of people being
buried at night show the death toll of
kovat 19 is higher than the government
of Daniel Ortega I would like to
acknowledge officially only 46 people
have died since the pandemic started but
independent sources say the number is
closer to 980 most death certificates
say the deceased died of a typical
pneumonia critics say the government was
also behind a campaign to convince the
population the pandemic will only attack
the rich we're battling Kobe 19 but
about extreme measures radical measures
that would kill the country and the
people we are keeping regular activities
open and taking special measures to
protect the most vulnerable
but among the dead are journalists like
Gustavo Bermudez who also allegedly died
of kovat 19 his relatives blame the
government for how he was treated they
killed him this is murder they did not
give us any information of what was
happening we will continue fighting as
Gustavo did nobody can say anything they
have a muzzle in the mouth the or takers
are the owners of Nicaragua they are the
owners of our lives doctors in the
country have created an independent
commission as reports show hospitals are
struggling to cope with the situation we
are the second poorest country in the
region we come after Haiti we have
horrible hygiene conditions trash
collection is not working in the capital
people don't have any water 24 hours a
day
the government has not taken any
measures to protect the population
Daniel Ortega has been naked I was
president since 2007 and has battled
opposition brutally in the past few
years the fear is that his denial of
kovat 19 will have devastating effects
in a country that is already in
desperate need Teresa Waugh al-jazeera